hello folks welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics right
everybody else does math
and
irrational explanations
here we do or try to do rational
explanations
uh physical mechanisms that you can
understand by simply
uh watching the movie you know put the
thing in motion there in front of your
eyes
okay we're going to do a little bit of
extinction followed by today we have the
start of a little mini series we're
going to look at uh opacity and
transparency
and then i'm going to
answer some questions that people ask
since last time okay
okay so let's get started i had a lot of
questions regarding covid everybody's
very concerned about this covet thing
uh
there's apparently a disease out there
some people believe it some people don't
and
it's on the one hand a health issue on
the other hand is a very
very
clear political issue okay
some people think it's just politics
other people think it's a health issue
okay so i had
questions or comments on both sides of
the fence there right and here's a
series of comments i got from the people
who looked at it from a health point of
view okay we have do you understand that
coronavirus uh have many animal vectors
so in six months the virus will mutate
evading the vaccine
in other words we develop new strains
right because
we're putting these vaccines so the
virus mutates and now you gotta invent a
new vaccine to kill that guy right he's
a little more powerful
the vaccine seems to be affecting
fertility someone says oh jesus
so uh
i guess negatively right uh
do we know maybe it affects us
positively maybe it gives you more kids
i don't know i don't know
what affecting fertility means it could
be positive for all i know right
you are not 100 organic human anymore uh
i never was you know um
i have um
uh
well in my case i have very little
inorganic stuff but i know people who
wear glasses
and
that's already uh you know inorganic
some people have their teeth replaced
that's uh also
quite inorganic and so on so you know
we're already quite inorganic just about
everywhere you know
uh we do a lot of uh artificial stuff on
our bodies people who do tattoos man
that's uh
you know maybe half the population the
young population does tattoos so uh
that's quite inorganic you're putting
all this ink inside your under your skin
right
and you know people who have prosthetic
legs or whatever so you know we're
already half robots
half androids
uh there's a lot of inorganic stuff out
there and uh it's a great measure
because people
need help of some kind you know not
everybody is born healthy or or someone
has an accident or whatever they need to
get some of these things done that's all
it is we know you didn't get jabbed
you're too smart to think viruses are
real
well i can tell you uh
you know
it's a subject i know very little about
so i don't get involved in that and it's
a subject i care a little about that's
why i don't even research it but my
overall theory is i guess the one the
establishment has okay and that is that
there are bacteria out there and viruses
uh we see them under the microscope the
bacteria you know something caused the
bubonic plague you know your xena pestis
and so on and so you know there are some
bugs there some microscopic bugs out
there
and to say that you know these bugs
multiply inside your body could be virus
which is really a molecule that
reproduces itself
or bacteria which is actually a living
entity that reproduces itself you know
for me it sounds logical and that's all
i can tell you uh some people say well
you know
they have different theories for this
and i've looked at some of those
theories and i'll stick with the
official version for now okay that's all
i can tell you that's the one i operate
under unless someone can show me
in a clear-cut matter
manner that there's no
there are no bacteria or viruses out
there and yeah i can imagine that there
are
a lot of these bacterium viruses that
multiply and hurt your body and there
are at the same time bacteria that you
have in your body that
are useful that we've uh we develop a uh
symbiotic relationship with so to speak
okay and they kind of protect us okay
uh
i heard that the what is the komodo
dragons has like
uh 80 or 90 uh almost unknown bacteria
in in its mouth
and when it bites its prey
you know it doesn't kill it and the
brain runs away and says oh
i made it and it turns out those
bacteria are so powerful they kill
the animal and then they you know the
dragon comes slowly in there and just
eats it up you know because he killed
him with the bacteria he's got in his
mouth and so
you know they looked at these bacteria
and these are something you can look
under the microscope of course you got
to be in that business but if you're not
in that business you can't say well
bacteria don't exist
well you know what are those i mean have
you ever looked inside a microscope and
seen any of these bacteria
so it's easy to talk and say well i
don't believe in all that well yeah
that's like you know believing in god
you know it's like i haven't seen god so
should i not believe in him or believe
in him because you know uh
i can't see or touch him what should i
conclude
okay so you know yeah all i can do is
tell you that
i just go with the official version for
now and again it's a subject that i'm
not interested in at all so i don't even
research it
and someone says you got a death
sentence
don't we all
we all haven't done best sentence ever
since we're born okay so
don't worry about that
uh you know uh am i going to die of
covert am i going to die because they
put a injected some poison inside my arm
probably not either way okay i'll
probably die of something else of
arthritis which is what i have for many
years now okay
okay uh
the other folk uh they uh
they bring it from a political point of
view okay they say this is all hoax okay
and so or or it's a hoax or they're
using it to control you okay one of the
two could be it's total hoax or it could
be that it's real but now the
powers that be are using this to
get a hold of you you know control your
behavior
watch out for new mysterious urges to
conform to support uh buy them to submit
okay
biden or any
politician for that matter right
i just don't get the shot because i'm no
i'm not going to cooperate with a new
tyranny
my body my choice okay
and i see it as their perfect excuse to
usher in a global restructuring of
society i can't see it any other way and
they'll get get it no matter how many of
us go down kicking and screaming
uh
meaning they're going to triumph anyways
so why worry about it right i mean if
they're going to win anyways if they've
got us controlled
and we can't do anything about it
uh maybe we shouldn't even worry about
it maybe don't lose any sleep don't
fight it anymore right
what should we conclude
and so you know we have these these
issues uh is there
covet out there is is there a real
bug out there that's the first question
we gotta uh look at
and uh
and again people say well bill you just
don't believe in conspiracies and
whatever you know i'm gonna say it in
reverse i'm no stranger to conspiracy
theories so here are some of my
arguments let me put them up here so
that we can follow along okay
first i'm no stranger to conspiracy
theories okay
i say that lincoln was murdered not by
well the gunman was john wilkes booth
but what i'm saying is uh it wasn't
johnny who uh masterminded this thing i
think it was uh edwin stanton who was
lincoln's secretary of war and i think
uh him and together with a whole bunch
of other northerners who wanted to
um take over the south okay
reconstruction as it came to be called
later on after lincoln's death uh they
they masterminded the murder of uh
lincoln okay
and uh you know i've gone through there
and looked at in the past uh just uh
skipped over more or less you know
skimmed over it uh you know i say roscoe
conklin was a stalwart that
masterminded the murder of james
garfield okay the trigger man was ghetto
charles guiteau uh but they were all
star wars and i think uh they
perhaps with chester a arthur they
realized that guiteau was a little off
his rocker and i think they
kind of manipulated him into killing
garfield
all of them are all these uh
conspiracies uh no i'm saying that for
example uh what's his name uh
leon chalgosh
guy who murdered um assassinated
president mckinley i think he acted
alone he was one of those few um
lone gunmen okay uh anarchist and i
think he acted alone i looked at that
history in quite a bit of detail and i
don't think there's anything in there
on the other hand uh you know
lee harvey oswald uh no not a long
gauntlet but no
by no stretch of the imagination okay
uh there's just too much to too many
people involved in there you know uh
with lee harvey oswald among them ruby
who
uh you know he was interviewed by by the
press once and he said
uh the people who put me in this
situation
and asked him like
who do you recommend
who are you referring to says the man
upstairs look at the man at the top
that was johnson
and yeah i'm sure that lo johnson and uh
steve your hoover masterminded the
killing of both kennedy's robert as well
and also of the of uh
martin luther king you know
they got rid of them
and uh 911
obviously george bush no problem there
this was the u.s uh and uh most sad uh
operation
okay
it's a standard practice for them on
normal stuff
nothing to be
excited about okay it was an exciting
thing to see you know the towers being
bombed okay
but uh to believe that this was done by
some barefooted hillbillies in
afghanistan well you know i i don't
think so
so i'm not a stranger to uh conspiracies
but the question is how far are you
gonna take it
i mean are we going to say everything is
a conspiracy
everything there was no julius caesar he
never existed they just put his name in
the book somehow and no napoleon
none of these people existed maybe uh
joe biden and and uh trump don't exist
either maybe these are just cartoon
characters created by i don't know the
klingons
and what you're staring i mean did you
ever shake the hands of joe biden
i mean so you've never seen them
directly right never shook hands with
them so
maybe joe biden doesn't exist maybe this
is just a hoax
i mean how far are we going to take this
whole thing okay
so what you don't want to become is a uh
an extremist
in coban you don't want to be a flat
earth
a copic flat earther okay
uh it's how far you want to take it and
so you got to choose your conspiracies a
little more carefully you know if you
think that the earth is flat and
everything's a conspiracy and that nasa
never sent the man to the moon
and that there are no real satellites
orbiting the earth that we're
communicating through uh sardine cans or
whatever you know
okay you can take it as far as you want
i mean at some point it goes into the
ridiculous level so um
is there a covet out there
well i don't know again
i'm not an expert on the subject all i
can tell you is my reasoning my
reasoning is that
i have a hard time believing okay
that iran north korea russia china and
the united states have reached an
agreement before the pandemic right and
they say why don't we
control our population why don't we
create this notion that there's a
disease out there okay and that'll give
us a chance to implement laws that will
help us control them
uh i have a hard time with that that all
these countries got together
you know humans are like lions
uh we don't share our pride with the
other guy we have to fight we we compete
okay
and to say that they all got together
and they all agree and then they form
this illuminati
new world order people who control the
flocks
uh and that they all agree up there i
have a hard time believing that i have a
hard time believing that for example
israel and the palestinians they all
agreed up at the top levels and they
said why don't we tell our respective
people that there's a covet bug out
there so that we get all these vaccines
and you know stab them with them and you
know and we can control them better
no i have a hard time believing
believing that you know
i think uh that's taking uh this uh
disease thing a little too far okay now
i think there there's got to be
something out there if all these
countries that have nothing
in common with each other
uh implemented some uh health measures
to control some kind of pandemic that's
spread throughout the world
uh and again i have no trouble believing
that uh some virus has infected the
population and spread
uh
it happened with hiv by the way you know
and and so you know the this is
it's happened with the bubonic plague in
the 14th century and so on there's been
plagues you know uh we've had smallpox
we had uh
you know so many of them out there we
had the yellow fever in
[Music]
what is it the end of the 19th century
1880s and so on so so we've had diseases
affect large portions of the population
and to say that these were all hoaxes
that there was no real disease out there
that there are no real bugs that we can
see under the microscope
um
i think that just takes it a little too
far okay at least for me okay so all i
can tell you is that okay uh so i'm
saying there is a bug
and um
and
now did they take advantage of that
politicians hospitals
health care workers whoever yeah i think
there's always that human aspect okay
that people suddenly you know take
advantage of something that's out there
in fact as soon as the uh
cobia thing hit you know you had all
these people selling mass others um
trying to corner the markets uh for uh
cleaning material you know and so on
that's normal human behavior
does that mean that these people in
advance created the virus so that they
could corner the markets on cleaning
material or whatever hospitals
uh saying oh now we're gonna have good
business we're gonna have more people
here at the hospitals
it's not gonna be for heart attack or
anything like that it's gonna be for
this
inexistent disease called covid
is that what all these hospitals around
the world did
i have a hard time believing that okay
in other words that they took advantage
after
the thing came out yeah
no doubt there but that doesn't imply
that it doesn't follow that they created
the bug an inexistent bug just to get
all these uh situations okay that's
where i have a problem
and again you have some winners and some
losers you know the tourist industry
with the help
okay no more hospital no more hotels no
more
restaurants no more flights you know
everybody stayed at home
and some companies like amazon you know
they would they did well because now
people are you know requesting things
through the internet
and uh
you know they say they have all these
delivery guys just deliver them the
things to their houses
and and there is a difference also in
the way of thinking of people who have
to go out there and work with lots of
people
versus the guy who is either unemployed
or works at home home office
that guy says oh yeah it's all a hoax
and i don't believe in all that yeah
because you're at home you don't have to
deal with people you don't have to you
know uh be with the crowds
that's a little different than the guy
who's got to be you know out there with
whatever job he's got where he's got to
meet lots of people
and he might say well you know i don't
believe but just in case i'm going to
get the shadow i believe a little bit
because
you know um
i'm going to be facing lots of people
and maybe one of them gives me the bug
and just in case you know
i'll be on the safe side and i'll
believe a little
so that's different guy who stays at
home and you know and just philosophizes
okay we have different situations there
so uh if you're too much into saying
that
this is a hoax
maybe you just don't have a job
maybe that's all you're saying
okay
maybe you're on welfare or whatever
okay uh so yeah once the bug is out
there a lot of people take advantage
make money off of it and that
unfortunately
creates these suspicions which are
totally justified people say hold it
all these people making money off of
this yeah and that's what they're doing
okay
okay so my corollary is just you know um
don't be a flat earther don't be a
covet flat earther don't take extreme
views on this
uh keep it within range okay
and all i can tell you is in my case uh
i took the shot only because i'm gonna
be traveling i didn't take it for a year
and a half because i wasn't planning on
traveling during that time and i did
travel
but then when i went to iceland i found
on how the authorities can make life
very difficult for you and i showed you
uh last time
here's uh one case a couple of um
news items that came out these are just
the headlines chicago now asks
vaccinated travelers to quarantine
another one biden administration tells
unvaccinated people don't travel over
labor day weekend europe wants
unvaccinated americans to stay at home
okay
uh here's a couple more that i picked up
this week netherlands titans travel
restrictions on u.s unvaccinated banned
vaccinated will need to quarantine
american airlines and pandemic leave for
unvaccinated staff and so on and so
forth okay
so um
uh do you think i'm gonna
fight city hall
i mean if you want to go ahead you want
to make a point you want to say well
they're not going to vaccinate me
they're not going to control me
in this case i accepted the chip inside
my head because it was easier to accept
that
than to fight all all this nonsense that
they're putting out there they've got so
many restrictions now on people who are
unvaccinated you might as well if you're
gonna travel
uh be on the safe side and just get
vaccinated i mean so far it hasn't
killed me uh i'm going to give my second
shot on what is 23rd of september
and after that i i don't think i'm going
to die immediately at least will i catch
the bug maybe i catch the next uh
version of it made the move the delta
the
zeta or whatever i mean i don't know
what next virus
the next strain will be okay i might
catch that and it might kill me for all
i know
uh i didn't get the virus the vaccine
because of
health reasons i got it only because i
don't want the hassle when i travel
that's it period you know
you want to take it further than that
that's fine uh so that's it and uh and
so my only issue with this whole vax
issue is
the economic draconian economic measures
the politicians have taken and so the
question is will the economy recover
from the draconian measures implemented
by politicians
um
i was uh
speculating you could say
that maybe what we should have done
is allow the
uh bugs
uh to kill whoever they had to kill just
let it let it do its natural job don't
create any vaccines
don't put any economic you want to
create vaccines fine no problem there
but
don't implement any
uh
measures political and economic measures
socio-political economic measures
um let people just do their regular work
normally let the tourism industry just
continue going as it was you know normal
as if nothing happened and those who
died die maybe more people would have
died no doubt about that probably right
but um
at least we wouldn't have messed with
the economy
and so the question is if saving a few
lives a few i'll even call it a million
lives
um was that worth
taking all these extreme
measures that will probably kill us
faster now because what they've messed
around with is what is really the cause
of extinction and that's the economy
bugs are not going to kill humans it's
going to be the economy that's going to
kill humans and with this i think
they've kind of accelerated the process
okay
i think it would have been better if
people died naturally and those who
wanted to get the vaccine get it don't
worry about anything else you know just
get the vaccine get yourself inoculated
get your self uh
to safety and those who didn't want the
vaccine just continue normal
but don't mess with the economy instead
they mess with the economy through
political measures
and i'm not even sure
how many lives they say maybe they saved
a lot even if they did
i think we
simply accelerated the process towards
extinction which is messing with the
real cause of extinction for man which
will be the economy
okay um
one person uh said
quarantine has historically been used to
segregate those those who are sick
he's got a point there okay
uh you don't you don't jail
the healthy you jail the sick you don't
jail the the honest people you you
jailed the criminals right
and here they did it in reverse they put
all the honest people in prison
and they said you got to stay in there
because we're protecting you
[Laughter]
okay
and so he says tyranny is when the
entire population
is restricted from movement without
permission okay
propaganda is when the media becomes the
tool of those in power to promote
tyranny under the pretense of quarantine
for your health benefit okay yeah and um
historically
i think that yeah
um
you know
when you've uh look at history
it was uh people who had the bubonic
plague who were isolated you know they
would put
a person who had bubonic plague they
would put them inside his room
keep them in there and the poor slums
right and everyone in this family had to
be in there together and they would they
would lock the door from the outside and
bolt it in and there was a guy standing
outside
put there by the government to make sure
no one came out of that room
okay so so the the person who had
bubonic plague he was in deep trouble
and so was his family because they were
all in there with him they could all die
for all anybody cared right
but they isolated that family from the
rest of the uh
their neighbors
and you know you've got this uh all over
the lepers you know they were put into
colonies
you had a
leper you know uh lovers were put into
colonies and so they always isolated
those who were sick
now they're isolating though or messing
around with those who are not sick
that's
that's a little different this time
around that's makes people suspicious
obviously
okay here's another positive virology
101
never mess never mass vaccinate during a
pandemic as the vaccinated will create
evolutionary pressure resulting in more
deadly strains by selectively destroying
the weak viruses while promoting the
more robust strains okay and he's
probably right as well i mean you know
uh the question does it make sense
to vaccinate uh in a pandemic are you
just accelerating the process
of creation of new strains
and so these are all good arguments as
far as i'm concerned right and again i
didn't get the vaccine because of health
issues nothing related to that it's not
that i panicked or anything like that i
could care less about the covet i don't
even know it exists out there you know
uh but since i'm going to travel i don't
want the hassle and i think i'm going to
get the hassle anyway because i'll just
give you a a
a for instance i'm going to go to a
fourth world country and it turns out
that you know i'm worried about
not being able to get out of there
okay vaccine or no vaccine they say well
bill you tested positive
for
uh in your pcr test you know put it up
your nose and your mouth and so on
and maybe you don't have the coven maybe
i don't have anything in there but they
say well you failed the test
so now you can't get on the plane you
can't return
and maybe they just want you know
you to grease their hands you know
you know so you might get into one of
those situations where maybe they mess
with you whoever you know is is the
judge in your situation where you have
to grease some hands in order for them
to put that stamp that allows you to
leave the country okay so i'm worried
about that more than than the kobe okay
so that's what's happening and again
those are because of all these draconian
measures that they've taken out there
okay
okay here's a
foul who talks about um
extinction here we talk about extinction
the covet is
like a uh secondary issue okay
the only concern there i have with code
again is
whether the uh the the issue about the
economics the fact that they've
implemented such uh measures out there
that affect us all okay and that hurt
the tourist industry you know hotels
restaurants
uh travel airline travel car rental and
all that stuff okay it says there was an
economic collapse in 1930s and we are
all still here
and roam collapse economically and we
are all still here okay so he says
there's been already collapses in the
past okay
and that's true i mean you have we've
had all kinds of uh
depressions and uh recessions
and throughout history okay
but
what's coming up is a little different
okay and here's the difference okay let
me just put some of the differences here
i'll get it on the other side give me a
second here
okay uh
it's got to do with this uh
globalization
today we have globalization something
the greeks did not have the persians the
romans none of those had globalization
okay they were local
now we have something that extends
throughout we have uh global empires
okay here the last empires by the way
okay there won't be any more empires
there won't be a single empire on earth
like a world government okay
communism
followed by anarchism where no
government is needed after that that was
mark's dream
uh i don't think it'll ever happen
at all you know we're not going to have
a world government and uh
again i'm saying that the united states
is going to be the last major empire out
there and it will not allow anyone to
surpass it before anyone surpasses it
there's gonna be war
for sure
okay anyways globalization of the
problem and i want you to understand
that international commerce is anywhere
from one-fourth to one third of global
gdp
okay so uh international commerce is
very important that means uh
and that wasn't the case
in the days of the greeks and the uh
persians and uh you know even even in
the uh 1930s
1930s we were still moving from
agriculture to manufacturing we were
still in this
transition uh from
one mode of production to the other mode
of production
and uh was in uh around 79 the days of
uh the um
what is it uh well
the standard i can't remember now the
name of it um where
around 1979 1980 uh the bretton woods uh
uh deal right of course that's when they
switched over from manufacturing to
services
and uh since then you know services have
ballooned okay they passed they left
manufacturing behind so we have a
different
uh economic system today than we had
just you know 40 50 years ago okay and
so international commerce is now a big
uh factor out there for every economy on
the planet that's one issue uh services
uh form up to in for the whole planet
anywhere between 65 and 70 percent
and uh in advanced nations even highers
80 or or higher
services is most of the economy
and what is services it's uh bs
services did not produce anything
uh oh oh you got it there uh all we do
is scratch the other guys back you know
i do a service for you you do a service
for the other guy and the other guy does
a service where the other guy
what is all that for
that all ends up in food
it allows you to buy food to live one
more day and maybe some uh
other items like chairs and houses and
streets
you know highways uh that that are solid
that are real things other than that
services is in a productive society
we're not producing anything with
services okay a person sings he didn't
produce anything and i know the
economist who goes you know he produced
something he's got value
they use that word value i know uh
services is nonsense there's no such
thing as services okay
the only real stuff is what god sees
from when he looks at the whole earth or
the devil whoever you believe in whoever
you pray to
he sees the stuff that is real the stuff
that is real are highways houses
uh the uh
fields of corn
you know
the boats the cars the airplanes that he
sees
he doesn't see the promises he doesn't
see insurance okay uh another or bitcoin
he doesn't see that that's nonsense uh
so all these uh services that we got out
there especially internet services
that's a bs economy that can
disintegrate like that
okay
and overnight because that's all just
faith
and so services is something different
than what we had in the 1930s okay
and then um uh yeah it's uh i call it
masked unemployment okay all we're doing
is just scratching each other's back and
we call that oh he did a service for me
he scratched my back and i scratched
joe's and joe scratch john's and so on
okay that's all services is it's a
nonsense economy
and now we're in that nonproductive
economy all that goes to produce what is
real which is a little bit of
manufacturing and almost
uh you could say none in terms of labor
and gdp of agriculture and the only
thing that keeps us alive is that one
percent
of agriculture that's what keeps us
alive agriculture and
you know
livestock and so etc right
all that is what keeps us alive one more
day
and we don't pay any attention to that
we don't pay attention to food
because it's like we take it for granted
food what are you talking about bill we
go to the store i can buy food anytime i
want it's always there
yeah wait till the economy collapses
let's see if you'll find it at your
nearest grocery store
okay uh one person says
there is no doubt any economic collapse
coming and
cities will be raised many will die and
comforts will be sadly lost
but i don't think a mass extinction
necessarily follows aha you'll find
communities forming outside of the
cosmopolitan heartland
communities uh what people will form
those communities if no one's left
uh after this collapse uh you're going
to see mass movements of these groups
mass movement what is this person
talking about
uh no there won't be any mass movements
because there won't be any masses
uh we're going to collapse because if
there is no food
why will there be any masses
can the masses live without food
where are they going to get food what
i'm saying is you know food will not be
produced because if money collapses
that's what we talk that's what we mean
when we say the economy will collapse no
longer are we talking about a recession
or a depression we're talking about
money disappears no one believes in
money anymore no one accepts money
anymore that's that's the situation okay
long story how we get there but right
now we're saying money is no more
if money is no more the corporations
that produce food have no longer any
need or any
you know
profit need right i mean why are
corporations in in business for profits
if there are no profits because money is
no more they have no reason to produce
food or distributed to the cities much
less to you why will you
and the masses
survive
so you know again that's why i always
ask people to do extinction 101
before they do extinction 102 please
tell me how the dinosaurs died and
hopefully you won't say that it was a
comet or an asteroid okay no
catastrophic accidents okay no volcanoes
no um
uh
new supernovas gamma rays none of that
nonsense because you cannot explain
selectivity with any of those
gargantuan uh
mechanisms okay so you got to do
mass i mean
mass extinction uh 101 before you do
human extinction which is 102. okay so
and that's what happens when these
people just
say well the masses will survive and
they'll move around and go this place
and that place because there's going to
be so much room
yeah sure
first tell me
uh how the masses will survive without
food okay that's what you gotta explain
okay so here's the million dollar
question for anyone who wants to tackle
it okay
will there ever be a last generation of
humans
will there ever be a last generation of
humans
because uh the first question you got to
answer is whether humans will ever
become extinct
before the sun collapses i mean right
now because if it's in a billion years
that's essentially saying that you don't
believe that humans are gonna become
extinct
okay
so the question is for those who think
that sense or have a sixth sense uh
feeling that humans will become extinct
someday okay
the first question is if that's the case
i i would assume there's gonna be a last
generation
okay
if there's a last generation how are
they going to die in other words what's
going to kill them why is there going to
be a last generation
okay what's going to kill is it just
because an asteroid hit the earth is
that what's going to kill us we're going
to wait for the asteroid meaning that if
no asteroid ever hits the earth we live
eternally is that what you're saying
or that if the asteroid comes and we see
it through our telescopes and blow it up
i don't know with a nuke
that we don't die either because we are
able to take care of those kinds of
problems because we can foresee the
problem
we have the technology to address it and
therefore it doesn't kill us
so again uh i'm talking about people who
actually
feel have this feeling you know
that humans will not live forever
and that they at some point will die
will there be a last generation and if
so
right
how will that generation die what will
happen to them why will they die what's
going to kill them i mean aren't they
intelligent aren't they can't they
foresee events don't they have
technology to counteract anything that
god throws at adam any act of god
what's going to kill them so you got to
come up with a mechanism that's that's
the task okay
uh for those again who believe that
humans are going to become extinct for
those of you who are religious and
believe that humans are going to live
forever
yeah
the question is not for you
okay let's move on to the subject matter
today what are we gonna talk about today
we're gonna talk about
uh
opacity
and
um transparency
why are some materials
like maybe glass or air how's there okay
or water how come they're
more or less transparent some are more
transparent than others i mean you can
see the water you can see
um
the glass in your window so it's not
completely transparent but you can see
through the glass you can see the tree
that's on the other side of the glass
okay
and others you know like
the brick wall that makes up your house
the cement wall you can't see through
that
how does mother nature distinguish how
does she do this this magic trick here
you can see through and there you can't
see through
okay
and so for this we have to start at the
beginning and the beginning is that uh
in this site at least
we do not follow the mathematical method
which some people call the scientific
method
we call it the mathematical method we
call it the mathematical method because
all the explanations physical
interpretations are irrational
they're not even you can't even
conceptualize them okay
and i'm not talking about easy stuff
like jesus christ going to heaven coming
back you know that's simple stuff that
god can do that okay he's powerful
enough
i'm talking about moving concepts
you know god cannot even do that he's
not that intelligent or that powerful
okay god cannot move a concept
and that's what we have in mathematical
physics that's what uh the mathematical
method led to
we had 400 years of the mathematical
method okay and so here are the issues
of the the different components the main
components of the mathematical method
which we do not follow here okay okay so
we have a different since the the
beginning of this century we had a
a paradigm shift
we have a new scientific method
and it has nothing to do with what i'm
going to show in a second here it's got
to do with what with explaining
science is about explaining if you
cannot explain something a mechanism in
physics right you are not a scientist
okay and i don't care if you have a phd
from harvard or cambridge
you are not
cambridge
you are not a scientist i don't care
what degree you have you're not a
scientist a scientist someone who can
explain something rationally okay we got
that so this is what the mathematical
method does which they call the
scientific method been around for 400
years at least
you could say galileo
newton all these folks from the 17th
century started this method and it's the
mathematical slash experiment method
okay
and so
we do away with that here in this site
so this is the first thing you have to
understand about this site in order to
follow the train of thought otherwise
you know you'll be lost okay and so here
it is okay here we have um
the mathematical method observation we
don't do observation we don't gawk
okay like uh
stevie gawking there okay we don't gawk
okay
uh the fact that you observed something
doesn't mean you understood what you
observed or that you can explain what
you observed so observing
uh just looking staring
you know drooling
uh
that does not mean that you're a
scientist
right so we eliminate the word
observation observer partly because
it's testimony and we do not accept
testimony in science okay testimony is
outlawed that's in the legal world in
the legal world the prosecutor says oh
brings a witness and says i observed i
saw
you know we don't accept that in science
in science uh you have to say let us
assume
you can't say i saw god
i observed god how did you observe god
well i saw the the the rose it's so
perfect who else could it be except god
who created the rose the perfection of
the rose well you didn't see god you
didn't observe god okay but you
put it in such a way like if you saw god
with your own eyes make the rose
that's the way mathematical physics
works in general okay they they take
this testimony and turn it into a fact
okay
we don't do predictions that's astrology
okay uh
we we don't do prediction we don't say
what's going to happen tomorrow or
please prove your theory uh by
predicting such and such things no we
don't prove theories and we do not make
predictions we explain the past we
explain consummated events
you have to explain something that
happened
okay that's the way it works
so the fact that you can predict that
tomorrow there's going to be an eclipse
does not mean that your theory is
correct
the reason and again a prediction is
just a description all you did is say
tomorrow there's going to be eclipse at
two o'clock
so what did you explain you haven't
explained anything yet you can't
haven't explained why you know
why you predicted this
but if you can explain it
it's because you're relying on
experience on the past you had some
experience with
uh
eclipses that's why you can explain it
explain past predict future we don't do
predictions in science that's religion
okay astrology okay so we don't do
predictions anyone using the word
prediction the word observation we kick
them out of science okay experiment we
don't do experiments
we say bill what do you mean we don't do
experiments in science no we don't do
experiments in science sorry to
misinform you
this inform you we don't do experiments
in science what we do is explain
experiments we don't do them
do we don't use our hands okay we don't
go to the lab and do an experiment what
we do is we go to the conference and
explain
how it happened
we explained the mechanism that's what
we do in science and the only reason
that the mathematicians introduce
experiments
is so that they can measure
and present it as evidence
they what do they present they present
an equation they present the
measurements they said here's science
i measured the table measures one meter
here's the equation give me my noble
that's the way mathematics works that's
not what we do in science in science we
do not measure we do not come up with
equations which is just a description
and we do not do experiments we have to
explain the mechanism we have to explain
how this universe works we need to know
how mother nature does gravity we need
to know how mother nature does
magnetism okay we need to explain the
mechanism mother nature uses for that
there is only one way
and that way is to make the invisible
objects visible the invisible mediators
you have to make them visible what
mediates gravity what mediates magnetism
what mediates electricity etc and light
you have to
you have to make visible the invisible
okay
and those who say well there is nothing
there there is nothing that mediates
gravity there is nothing that mediates
magnetism one magnet attracts another
but there's nothing in between
you are in effect introducing black
magic
in that in your explanation you're
introducing spirits in that space
so those people who say there's nothing
there because you can't see or touch it
they're religious folks they're
introducing spirits and they're
explaining with black match they're
saying one man attracts another
uh by act of magic
nothing nothing in between no physical
entity between the two magnets that's
what they're saying
so you have to identify have to make
visible whatever is in between two
magnets
if you can't make visible what's between
two menus you are not a physicist you
are not a scientist i don't care what
your degree is
that's the way it works in science okay
measurement we don't do description math
is just description math is only a
religion that does
descriptions
uh has nothing to do with science
mathematics mathematics an equation it
can only describe it's only a
description
mathematics is a language actually
language of adverbs quantitative adverbs
and nothing but
okay
mathematics uh is the branch of
mathematics that tries to give a
physical interpretation to the equation
and that's when they get into all this
irrationality where they start moving
concepts such as field and waves and
vortices and who knows what energy
information they transfer information
i got hit with information they
transferred into my face
okay uh credentials we don't pay
attention to credentials that's uh stuff
that the vatican does i think you know
the pope
they rely on authority the authority of
the bible of god you know we don't do
this we don't care what degree you have
you can have a phd a master's it doesn't
matter to us
please explain if you cannot explain we
don't care what your degree is
okay so the uh you and you can't say oh
i got a noble yeah who gave it to you
your your buddies
i mean so you gotta know but what do you
what did you explain
what can you explain
can you explain gravity the mechanism
can you explain magnetism can you
explain electricity can you explain
light can you explain the workings of
the atom
can you show us your atom
what does it look like is it this
planetary thing that goes around
so again we have a problem with people
who just use authority and say oh but i
got a phd
yes
who cares
you all you did was suck up that that's
why you got a phd from cambridge or or
harvard
i mean if if
if the guy
your your supervisor
your uh you know advisor
if you didn't bow down to einstein
i'm sure he wouldn't have given you the
your phd in mathematics okay so
in fact the phd shows quite the opposite
if you've got it in mathematical physics
right if you got it in mathematical
physics because
you know you know nothing about physics
absolutely nothing all you did was suck
up that's why you got that degree and
all you do is parrot the party line uh
you just memorize the catechism you're
just reciting poetry
okay uh voting we don't vote we don't
raise our hands we don't vote for
theories not in science we do that at
the congregation on sunday school you
know we go to sunday school we all vote
for god
and for the bible
uh that's where they vote for uh for
theories okay yeah god created the
universe
and so uh you know all this voting that
hey all the scientists on earth believe
this well we don't care they could all
be flat earthers for all we care
it doesn't mean that their theory
matches what mother nature does out
there mother nature laughs at these
people if if they come up and say well
gravity is warped space time and a
particle can be at two places at once
uh i don't think so i don't think mother
nature likes that at all yeah
and present we don't win prizes no
beauty contests in uh in science you
know they have these prizes the wolf
prize and the uh what is it the nobel
prize
we don't give prizes in science okay
it's in religion where they give prizes
and they certify knowledge they say i
got a medal i have certified knowledge
now i can trounce anyone i want because
i've got authority right go back to our
30. now the medal gives you authority
gives you credentials
so we don't care about credentials okay
none of that works in science science
you got to explain that's science okay
we have the satisfaction of being able
to explain and not the satisfaction of
winning a medal
this is not the the olympics where you
win a medal for running faster or
whatever okay
and censorship we don't censor you know
like they do in mathematics you're not
allowed to publish in mathematics
they run all the magazines because these
magazines and
journals have been around for many years
now hundreds of years
and so they don't allow anything which
does not have an equation
to be printed in their magazines and
that's the way they censor you they say
no no you got to come through our
mathematical method
if you want to publish here
and so if you don't publish there
the public doesn't see it
because
partly because there are
translators of
you know this
mathematical uh world where they publish
all this nonsense all these physical
interpretations and there are people who
kind of translate that for the public
and you know they have blogs they have
articles out there that more or less
turn what this guy discovered
allegedly discovered in his office or in
his lab and they kind of translate that
for the public so they serve as
intermediates uh intermediaries
uh between the so-called scientists and
the public right and so you can't get
your stuff to the public why because in
order to publish
there you have to put an equation
i mean go to almost any paper out there
any paper okay
from mathematical
physics
and you won't find a single drawing you
won't find a single picture
what you'll find is just a bunch of blah
blah and equations and
words that you can't even pronounce
because they've invent new concepts
every day
and you won't find a single expl
rational explanation you won't find a
single picture because if you saw a
picture
you would say okay i see what he's
saying he's saying this because i can
see it in the picture
but there they deal only with concepts
and so you won't find a physical
interpretation which they dismiss as
philosophy okay they say no you're in
the wrong place bill you got to go to
philosophers uh across campus so you go
to the philosophers okay you're the
philosophers philosophers of science
and so now you ask them okay look i'd
like to publish my article here what's
it about bill wits about how the world
works
and uh it debunks quantum and relativity
and spring theory
and they say well we take our cues
from the mathematical physicist so you
can't publish here either
so they have the whole place control you
can't publish your sensor
okay because you're trying to give a new
physical interpretation even to the same
equations right
but they won't allow you to do that they
don't want physical interpretation they
don't want them in mathematical physics
and they don't want them in philosophy
of science etc
they don't want it at all so you can't
publish you can't
get to these people because nobody wants
to hear you okay so there is censorship
in that sense now is it censorship
because it's deliberate like there's a
conspiracy uh i don't think it's like
that it's more like uh they've got their
own world
and if you don't fit in their world they
just won't allow you to publish because
they're into a different world they just
want math
and so it's not like i'm saying there's
a big conspiracy or anything it's just
that's the way the
so-called science mathematics
developed
okay okay so that's the starting point
so if if you're in this site and you
don't understand that that
we we
reject the mathematical method and we
have a new scientific method which has
to do with
um uh
physical interpretations with
explanations rational explanations of
how mother uh nature runs her shop okay
uh unless you understand that you're
lost here you're gonna be lost here okay
that's the first thing we got to say so
how what does uh mathematical physics
propose
well they do everything with this they
do everything with either particles or
waves transverse waves
everything is mediated for the last 400
years with these two proposals we have
particles and we have transverse waves
what's the problem with that i mean
you'd say well okay so what's wrong with
this
okay we have a lot problem with this and
the first one is that the particles
eight particles that's the first problem
okay
particles ain't particles
not according to quantum for the last
hundred years we have gotten rid of the
corpuscle
so whenever they show you something like
that
uh that's wrong
okay what you're staring at is a lie
or or they're misdirecting you they're
mis
what you're staring at is something
that's being misconstrued
you think there are little corp muscles
moving
uh at the top right the particles
that are moving to the side and that's
not what's happening
okay what is a particle we got to start
there what's a particle okay and here's
a particle okay
particles is a field okay that's what a
particle is
okay so uh you say what do you mean a
field yeah it's a vibrating field the
field is this uh three-dimensional uh
spider's web that stretches all the way
to infinity or at best the edge of space
time one of the two whichever one you
want okay so that's a particle for them
and uh when you stop it you know when
you take a measurement or whatever it
looks like this
okay there you stopped it now that's a
particle okay
and uh you say well what's all that
other
uh three-dimensional spiders well uh
well let's get rid of it so it doesn't
bother your eyes okay this is what a
particle looks like okay
we got rid of all the other stuff so it
doesn't interfere with your
interpretation that's a particle
so so what they've done is they have
this field
and when
you have what is called the wave
function collapse
okay wave being this whole field this
wavy thingy that they've never
identified just a bunch of numbers that
spread out from ground zero okay
uh when they take a measurement when
they put their probe there or their
detector
that's when the whole thing collapses to
a point
okay and then that's their notion okay
of what a particle is
so we're not talking about a thing we're
not talking about a little ball we're
not talking about a little bead what
they're talking about is a field
which is what a bunch of numbers because
that's what a field is field is uh just
a bunch of numbers in space different
values different strengths of whatever
of
electricity of magnetism of gravity okay
just different values of that and when
you
go to the center of that whole
bunch of numbers vibrating numbers
that's when you find a particle what's a
particle is just the function collapse
pinpoint no size no radius no nothing no
volume
uh
but it's a value that now you can put in
an equation
that's what a particle is now
so when they show you and they say well
these particles move they're not talking
about particles because when you put
them against the ropes and start
pummeling them and say what is a
particle they say well a particle is not
a particle not a corpuscle
here you got to take math to understand
what a particle is
that's what they tell you how about the
wave does it do any better well here's
the transverse wave okay
okay and so uh what are we talking about
there well it's a bunch of vectors those
blue and red arrows
those are vectors and each one of those
represents
okay here we have this engine arrow and
it represents it stands in for what
magnitude and direction that's what
you're staring at and so what you have
is magnitude and direction of a
gazillions of
magnitudes and direction that are moving
that's what what a transverse wave is
okay the so-called field the electric
and magnetic fields that's what they are
they're just a bunch of numbers that are
moving
okay so we don't have
particles
real particles and this is what a wave
is
okay that's what you got to live with
so we don't have a single physical
object in front of us and that's what
they pretend to do physical
interpretations with
at the end of which they say well we
don't understand it either and that's
philosophy anyways go to the
philosophers philosophers say no go to
the mathematicians because they are the
ones who give us the information that
we're supposed to analyze
and that's it that's what we have today
okay so
uh you figure out
okay um
so
let's look at uh because
this is the foundation i'm
giving you so that you understand
how we're going to get to this opacity
and um
transparency okay
and today i'm just i want to make clear
this the following this is a mini series
this is only the first of the the series
so there's going to be a million
questions well how about this how about
this exception one last exception
there's going to be lots of exceptions
i'm going to cover them in the next
couple of sessions okay lectures today
i'm only going to cover one aspect
just one aspect i'm going to show you
just one aspect of what underlies
opacity and transparency okay let's keep
that in mind so you're gonna have a
million questions and hopefully you do
because that maybe puts you to think
of what other factors could be involved
in opacity and transparency okay so it's
good that you think so hopefully today i
just get you to think okay okay so let's
start here
here we have uh
waves okay
and
the question with waves is
does a wave does a component of a wave
okay in this case water wave
is that
why that component
you know does that one is that the one
that reaches your body is that the one
that touches your body
i mean if you look at waves coming from
europe to the united states or vice
versa
is the little
water molecule here the one that
from
europe the one that reaches
all the way to
north carolina and just
waves you
it doesn't travel all all that whole
space
that whole distance
and now you can see here that the the
wave is not made
the water molecule is not traveling
what it does it kind of twirls in place
the deeper you go the smaller the
the the
exciting excitement okay of that little
wave the smaller the circle
but the wave is what continues so so
we've got a difference between the wave
and the water the water stays in place
more or less okay it's local whereas the
wave whatever this wave is
verb
that move it's a mirage it's like
there's something moving that causes
pressure but whatever causes pressure is
not something that came from over there
and pushed
it's just the last few molecules that
are pushing okay so uh it goes like this
you know it's like the last few
molecules are always the same ones that
are pushing it's not that the molecule
from
uh europe
hit
north carolina okay
that's what i'm saying and here you have
another version of this uh more or less
just to illustrate it for you okay you
can see that the particles are not
really moving in other words sideways
they're just moving up and down or or
circulating locally right
so what do we learn from this we learned
that the
waves
whatever waves are
mother nature's waves
is not traveling through
it doesn't go through
it vibrates locally
and whatever it is that's vibrating and
the wave is this mirage this thing this
verb
okay that uh
you see movie it causes pressure at the
other end you feel the pressure and you
say oh the wave traveled
no the wave did not travel in other
words the there is no such thing as a
wave what happened is the particles
moved up and down and that movement up
and down caused pressure
the
molecules that were in contact with you
those are the ones that cause pressure
and they keep causing pressure it's more
or less the same molecules it's not like
a molecule traveled from over there and
came and pushed on you
okay so let's keep that in mind okay
okay how about sound
it sound any different air right and now
it turns out it's the same thing here
you have a few red particles and you can
see that
we're going to think of those as oxygen
molecules o2 okay
and the particle more or less stays in
place when i talk
what you're listening is something
that's vibrating the molecules close to
your ears
hopefully the molecule that's coming out
of my mouth when i blow or when i make a
sound or whatever vibration hopefully
that's not the one that reached all the
way to your ears okay what what got to
your ears the vibrations of the
molecules close to your ears
again mother nature doesn't send
particles through or waves through
she has them vibrating up and down or
back and forth okay
and what reaches you are just the
molecules that are close to you
okay so i just want to make sure uh
we're understanding this part of it okay
uh here's a
a phonon okay more or less the same
thing but his phone on uh the particle
of sound okay here's what the particle
of sound
okay so the particle of sound is not
really
uh
one particle that hits your ear or
whatever
what it is is a bunch of
molecules or or atoms could be that are
more or less moving in situ in place and
the whole thing
um waves okay the whole thing waves uh
you know there was all the molecules all
the atoms wave as a whole okay and
that's what they call a phonon okay they
refer to this thing that you're staring
at there as a phonon
so
i hope you're getting the idea the idea
is that waterways
you know the water molecule does not
travel from
europe to the united to the coast of the
united states and hits you okay that's
not the that's not the water molecule
that hit you the one that hit you is the
last one that was there okay the wave
did not travel because there is no such
thing as a wave what it is the water
moved up and down
more or less right they move sideways as
well but more or less in the same
location and what hits you is the
molecules that they've pushed that's the
one that causes pressure against you
air molecules same thing
it's the air molecules that are close to
my ear that are
you know moving in there there's
rarefaction and compression of of air
molecules in there but it's the one that
are closer to my ears
the sound is moving
the air here which moves this one here
that moves that one there and moves the
one that's close to my ear it's not that
the
particle the oxygen molecule from here
went all the way to my ear
okay that's what i'm trying to say here
okay
okay here's uh gravity how does gravity
work okay let's find out here
so it says
so here let's start here if the sun
disappears the gravitational disturbance
that the results will form a wave that
travels across okay this is from the
mathematical establishment okay
and uh it says the spatial fabric
meaning space time right in much the
same way that a pebble dropped in a pond
makes ripples that travel across the
surface of the water okay so what is
this about they say that if the sun were
to disappear right you you would not
feel the
the earth would not feel the um
difference in gravity until eight
minutes later which is the time it takes
for what for the wave to travel
okay the wave has to reach from the from
the sun to the earth and they claim that
that cannot travel faster than light and
so the fastest it can go is eight
minutes which is the distance uh light
would have to travel from um or the time
the uh
light would have to travel from um the
sun to the earth okay and so gravity at
best can travel at the same speed that
means if the sun were to disappear which
is what we see there
uh the waves that of of gravity right
that travel through space
okay
uh would take eight minutes to reach the
earth and earth would not fly away until
eight minutes later this is the standard
version this is what
the mathematicians came up with okay
and so um
is this what's happening is this uh
what the sun is doing the sun is sending
you gravity waves
through the space what is space well
space they say is made out of particles
okay uh that's what quantum mechanics
proved
in the lab that space is made out of
positive and negative particles
okay so uh is the sun just sending waves
through this ether
or
or is it the ether that is vibrating and
that's gravity i mean what's the story
here
what is it that's uh what is this wave
of gravity that's coming towards the
earth and again as you can see the uh
sun is sending these waves out should
that push the earth outwards
why would it uh hold the earth in place
if it's pushing in one direction
okay and again mother nature doesn't
seem to work this way mother nature does
all these waves in situ
locally okay
and so if this is their notion of waves
that of gravity waves that gravity is
something that emanates
and comes towards you
i don't know uh that's kind of hard to
believe because mother nature doesn't
seem to do waves that way water waves or
sound waves
light waves maybe
okay how do
you do light waves okay
okay here's electricity okay let's find
out electricity
okay and here they don't do it with
waves here they do with particles
you have the classical version which is
the
electric uh the electron moving from
atom to atom and i call that the
classical one to distinguish it from the
quantum one which they got rid of the
atom all together quantum does it with
electron beads they say electricity is
just a bunch of electron beats flying
through space
that's what they claim today
and you can see ours is the only one
that
has the wave notion in-situ
rotation of merged electron shells
okay
and so ours is a
wave a true wave it's a this wave that
mother nature uses in other words
there's nothing traveling like in the
case of the particles
it's it's just rotating in situ okay so
i just want to distinguish that okay so
that you can see
that we have a different version okay
okay and uh yeah the with the quantum
version you cannot explain anything
because you don't have an atom to begin
with here's their atom okay and uh we
cannot explain why that bead doesn't fly
away spontaneously that's rolling around
the planetary model and we don't know
why that b doesn't fall to the center of
the atom so we cannot justify under the
quantum version why that b just jumps
back and forth between energy levels and
if you cannot justify that then you
cannot explain current which is what
they say is the flow of electron beams
from atom to atom or without atoms just
the flow of electron beams which is
essentially the quantum version today
okay so
so
quantum mechanics has no explanation for
anything it has no explanation for
gravity for uh electricity
for
water and air i mean are they saying
something is traveling through the wave
is traveling through
is that the version
or are we saying that uh something is
vibrating locally and that causes
pressure which is totally different than
saying that the particle came from over
there and hit me
those are two different mechanisms okay
so right now uh quantum mechanics has
this uh billard board uh
billard ball uh mechanism where they
just shoot balls
back and forth
and mother nature doesn't do waves that
way okay that's the point i'm trying to
make okay keep this in mind okay we're
gonna explain opacity and transparency
with all this
believe it or not okay so here we go uh
magnetism
um in order for you to have magnetism
you have to align the domain somehow
okay
uh and you can see they're all pointed
in the same direction
okay so that's
something you should keep in mind okay
that
um you have to align alignment is
the key issue
okay
today okay today i'm just going to talk
about alignment okay
and we're talking about going through
and we're going to talking about waves
okay
waves are not going through
okay you can't say a wave
went through okay wave is something
whatever that something is vibrating in
situ
that causes
the go through
wave
okay
so this verb that goes through is not
really something going through that's
where people are mistaken okay
the thing that is waving is waving
locally
and it allows whatever
to go through
and they call that whatever a wave
but there is no such thing as a wave
because wave is the verb
which is the
effect of those particles moving in situ
okay i got that
through you okay
that's the one i want to make so
magnetism requires
the alignment of domains alignment is
one condition to get something to go
through whatever that go through is okay
and the way we do it in um in quant in
uh the rope model
here we have two atoms bound by
electromagnetic rope that's our model
here you have the two-dimensional atom
in the three-dimensional atom we just
put the simplest atom two hydrogen atoms
there that's more or less what they look
like okay
construction you'll find in some other
videos that we have out there but this
is essentially the model
and with that we're going to try to
produce
magnetism and the way we produce
magnetism is we have many electron
shells which are merged to each other
they are aligned which is the subject
matter here they are aligned they rotate
in place and what they do they swing the
threads that make up the ropes and the
electron shells around themselves
so
the
um magnetic field is actually composed
of threads which are swinging around the
atoms that's the invisible stuff that we
cannot see between two magnets okay so
that's our argument okay so you know
where we're coming from
and uh here's an experiment we did with
my wife the other day and it looks more
or less like this
we have
two polarizing lenses and you can see
that light goes through them when
they're aligned but when they're not
aligned light does not go through the
lens it becomes opaque
okay
so this going through
uh
stops when you just turn it around and
if light is some kind of wave well maybe
nothing is going through i mean are we
throwing a stone
through those lenses is that what the
photon is a little photon that's
penetrating there and going right
through the glass
is that what we're seeing and since we
have gazillions of these you know when
light hits the window it hits every bit
of your window so we're saying
gazillions of photons are hitting your
window none of them broke your window
they just went through the window
so again the question is whether light
which is some sort of wave phenomena
is a
is a local vibration of something rather
than going through
and that's one issue the other issue is
whether you need alignment and there you
see that apparently alignment has
something to do with opacity and
transparency in one direction you have
transparency and the other one you have
opacity
and all we did was just
realign the molecules that make up those
two
lenses
okay
so how do we start this uh
how do we start to explain this
phenomenon
well
i do it with calcium calcite
i'm sorry calcium carbonate and
the molecule looks more or less like
this okay you have carbon you have
oxygen and you have calcium that's what
these molecules look like uh the shells
this is the shell structure
of these atoms when you put them
together they build a calcium carbonate
molecule which is the one on the right
and it's more or less like that
gingerbread man there a little calcium
big head on the top
uh three oxygen molecule uh
atoms tied to the or bounded to the
carbon and also to the calcium okay so
that's more or less what the calcium
carbonate molecule looks like and this
thing for some reason is transparent in
one direction but when you put it in
another direction and somehow becomes
opaque
so mother nature using this little
molecule one of the molecules that does
uh
polarization uh is giving us a clue that
something is happening
to um
in the direction in which the molecules
are pointed okay
and so uh one question you might want to
ask yourself is
you know if you look at the wall cement
wall or brick wall
you can't see through it
if we were to align okay if we could if
we had the power of god right and we
could align all the molecules that build
your brick or your cement
would the wall be transparent would you
be able to see through it
because what we're doing is relaying
okay that's the suggestion here that's
the proposal
that that's what's happening when you
have transparency
in a polarized film whereas when you
turn the other one around 90 degrees no
longer aligned
and so now you don't have transmission
okay
being no transmission whatsoever being
relay okay and so here's uh the
mechanism okay i explained that the
other day here you have one of these uh
carbon uh
calcium carbonate molecules we have
these gingerbread men tied one next to
each other okay
and what we're gonna do next is we're to
rotate two of these we're going to have
one behind the other okay so we're going
to have a couple slabs of this material
okay here you have them they're
connected by ropes okay
and so we have the first slab which is
made of several layers
of these gingerbread men and calcium
carbonate and have another slab behind
it light goes through
it's transparent so we're saying that
all these
uh slabs are connected
directly from the laser
to the first slab to the second slab to
the screen all in a straight line so
light goes through it because it's
relayed from one
slab to the other all the atoms are
aligned that's what i'm saying okay
and when we turn them around we rotate
one of them okay now what happens is
uh they're no longer in a straight line
okay so when you rotate one of the slabs
what you have done to the ropes okay is
the ones that were connected in a
straight line are no longer connected in
a straight line
okay so it's a question of alignment
okay this is one of the
mechanisms okay
there could be a different mechanism as
well let me explain that one
give me a second here
get this out of there
okay and this is the other mechanism and
that's uh
we have a rope okay
and
uh right now uh
remember this is torquing at great
speeds speed of light
and uh so this is
torquing constantly
but it's got a certain frequency what is
frequency what's a certain link length
the length of the link is from where the
blue starts to where the red ends okay
we'll call that a link okay and so what
do we have there one two three links
okay
what happens
uh when you turn
one of the slabs around at 90 degrees
well you're torquing the rope okay
you're torquing the rope at a different
frequency of different wavelengths
and so suddenly you know you went from
this
to this and so that's also happening
when you turn one of slabs at 90 degrees
with the respect to the other so you
have two phenomena at least that i can
think of maybe you can come up with a
third one or a fourth okay
uh that is happening when you turn one
over around the point here is that
in order to get transmission you have to
have them aligned when you don't have a
line you have opacity so you have trans
transparency and you have opacity
okay so that's the point that i'm trying
to make
and so these are my conclusions for uh
transparent for today remember this is
not the only we're gonna have some more
stuff here and i hope that you think
about this and come up with
more ideas okay because i'm going to be
covering them in the next couple
lectures but these are my conclusions
today
sound
uh it requires in-situ vibrations not
travel through okay water waves uh in
situ vibrations there's nothing
traveling through
okay which is the quantum version okay
gravity uh waves um
don't travel through okay
uh
here you have i mean what what is waving
is it the ether is it space made of
particles is that what's waving up and
down
or is space there just sitting there
whether it's a bunch of particles or
nothing whatever you choose and you have
this wave from the sun just come out and
reach you
and you might say well that's what the
sun does its sun sends us
electromagnetic waves
so does it also send us gravity waves in
the same way you know some thing that we
can't see
because we can see the the one that the
light you can see you know it hits you
it uh tans you right and so how about
the gravity is it sending you a gravity
wave what is this gravity wave that is
sending you is it also a transverse wave
so again
gravity is not traveling through okay so
going through this is the notion you
have to get rid of this traveling and
going through
electricity
is it particles going from modern atom
are the particles are the electron beads
going through
the film or whatever iron or whatever
your wire is made of
or are they
turning in place
okay
is the wave of electricity
something that throws in place or is a
little bead really going from positive
from negative pole to positive pole
is it traveling all that at the speed of
light
so this is what we gotta look at
magnetism uh you have to align the
domains
if you don't align the domains you have
a piece chunk of iron
you want that iron to pick up something
uh
magnetically
you have to align the domains then it
becomes a magnet okay so alignment
polarization
here you have alignment and here you
have disalignment okay you don't have
alignment when you turn one of them 90
degrees and suddenly we went from
transparent to opaque
okay so that should make you stop and
think that maybe mother nature one of
the mechanisms she uses
is the alignment of molecules
alignment and gives it
something about the nature of light it
has a wave nature but the way the way
mother nature does waves is not by
sending through
but by doing something in situ whatever
is there is moving
spiraling
in
situ locally
okay
and of course with a rope you can
explain that
rope is in situ twirling okay each one
of those links is what the
mathematicians confuse for photons and
they think that the photons are
traveling
when what's happening is really
something is truly
in place
okay
so that's the first
uh installment okay the first
installment is that
alignment
is
necessary
for to do waves and to do transmission
and if you don't have alignment
you have opacity okay that's the first
installment we'll go with the other
things that mother nature uses
in the next couple sessions
okay let's get to the questions that
people asked okay
one file says
like this one
says uh can this guy make a video
without using the words flat earth in it
gets upset because uh i beat up on the
flat earthers well i beat up on the
electric universe i beat up on the
quantum guys i beat up on all of them
they're all they all do religion none of
them does a rational explanation okay we
need to have rational explanations for
how mother nature runs her shop
otherwise we're introducing spirits and
black magic okay and so yeah flat
earthers flat earthers are primarily
into
uh conspiracy theories okay
and again i'm not a stranger to
conspiracy theories but you can take it
to an extreme which is what the flat
earthers do and they say well we never
went to space and there are no
satellites going around the earth
and uh and it's all the hoax and the
earth is really flat and i can't go to
antarctica because there's these these
military that won't allow me to see the
wall of ice because if i discovered that
i would discover that the earth is flat
okay yeah sure
go to antarctica and then tell me okay
go to the south pole and stay there
okay here's uh another following he says
what on earth do we need to look at the
molecular level for
elastic inelastic and tension
compression for the cubes and spring if
we don't need to look at any deeper at
the single piece thread for fluidity and
friction
he proposed the other day two cubes the
only thing that god made two cubes i
think he put them bounded by a string or
whatever
i'm not sure about that but the two
blocks came together and he said will
they
bounce or will they stick
that was his question and so he's he's
asking for a prediction
okay who do this prediction religious
people uh electric universe uh quantum
people uh relativist those are the
people who do predictions okay in
science we don't do predictions
it says i personally cannot rationally
imagine any single piece object that
isn't also totally rigid
okay
and an inelastic collider
okay meaning that um
uh he says these cubes are made of a
single piece okay
totally rigid
and that
they collide
and that he says that it ain't
inelastic okay
okay you're telling us there can be a
single piece a single piece springs
yeah he talked about a piece of string
springs made of single pieces you try to
say what happened with the spring can
you stretch it or not okay the question
is what compels a stress spring of a
single piece to move once we let it go
okay
it's no different from the question of
what compels the rope to do gravity when
i take a coin to the top of the empire
state and let go
seems like starting motion creationism
uh no you were already moving
before you let go of the
uh
you were already moving before you let
go of the coin okay the coin was already
moving okay because you're moving with
respect to jupiter you're moving with
respect to the andromeda galaxy every
micro second of the day okay so you're
already moving you couldn't start motion
because you're already in motion okay
and so again uh
i cover that in my book where i say you
know let's assume god uh created a
static universe you know a frozen
universe it's completely frozen
and then god sets it in motion okay
and what does he need to do to set it in
motion
does he need to make all these atoms
move
no absolutely not
god doesn't need to move the whole
universe
all that god needs to do is move
one atom
as soon as he moves one atom
all other atoms in the universe move
with respect to that atom
so if you want to move god all i need to
do is move your pinky
and now the distance between my pinky
and god is moving every time i move it
and so god is being moved
by my little finger
my pinky or my index finger
okay i can move god very easily all i
have to do is move my finger like that
and i and i move god because god is
moving with respect to my finger okay
the distance is changing okay that's
what
motion is and uh so god only needs to
move a single atom in the universe and
the rest of the atoms
in the universe change their location
with respect to that single
particle okay
so no we don't need to move the whole
universe the universe was moving now
regarding what this fellow is asking
well he's asking questions
again that he's trying to analyze the
thread the single thread
under our everyday macro world
experience
and i'm saying you can't do that and he
just insists and keeps going back there
you know how am i gonna
imagine something that is made of a
single piece which is malleable
and yeah that is the proposal and how
did we arrive at that we arrived
retrospectively we said look
this is what the rope does the rope
produces life produces gravity etc you
know we've got all these mechanisms for
how the rope does all these things
gravity uh magnetism electricity and so
on
and now from there we say well you know
if a rope ends in an atom and an atom
ends in a rover open an atom at a minute
oh what you have is
you know what does that go infinitely uh
eternally whatever no
we have a closed loop thread that makes
up all of matter
and so for that closed loop thread you
can't say what is the thread made of
well if i tell you what the thread is
made of i'm in bigger trouble
because if i say well the thread is made
of all these particles i'll call them
the particle x
and then the guy said well what is x
made of
well see if you chop up the little
particle x that makes up the thread
you'll get the particle y
what is the y made of
and so it never stops
never stops
that's why quantum is an irrational
proposal because quantum has that
situation
the
reporter at the end of the room says
well what is the muon made up well it's
made out of this
and what is the
what is the x made out it's made out of
wine what is the y minor it's made out
of z's give us more money we'll build a
bigger collider we'll smash it and we'll
tell you what that's made out of
that's the religion of quantum mechanics
no no in science we do it else in a
different way we say
there is an
elementary or fundamental entity we call
it the thread
what is a what is a fundamental
elementary entity
by definition it's something that is not
made of something else it has no parts
to it you cannot say the threat is made
of something because then you're an
irrational individual
you still
haven't come down to earth with your
mind
you cannot say the thread is made out of
particles out of
smaller particles or smaller parts
because it never ends everybody's going
to ask well what is that particle made
out of and you're going to be there
forever
no we stop the buck stops there at the
thread the thread is the fundamental
entity that makes up everything else
it's an
elementary fundamental entity what is an
elementary fundamental entity it's one
that is not made of smaller parts
now you say well if it's made out of a
single piece it's got to be rigid
because that's our experience in our
everyday world a steel beam is not made
out of a single piece but
it's very rigid and i'm sure that if we
could blend it in such a way that all
the
atoms get rid of all the space in there
so that it's made out of a single piece
you would say well that's rigid
but we don't have that situation really
in our real world
okay we don't have that situation where
we have something made of a single piece
so you cannot say that something which
is made out of a single piece
is
not malleable
okay so here we have the single piece
thread and it is malleable and you
cannot continue saying
well i cannot imagine that i cannot
imagine how it can be made a single
piece and it is malleable
and again we have to arrive at that
conclusion in retrospect
to come up with the properties of the
thread
and these are properties that you will
not find in our macro world as the
quantum people have already figured out
after 100 years that you that the
quantum world works a little different
in our world of everyday experience our
macro world
so you have to make some radical
assumptions about the entities that
mother nature uses
invisible intangible entities that
mother nature uses to do her everyday
work okay and so if you say well when i
drop the pen there's nothing and
there you have gravity you know because
it's pulling the pen somehow pulling you
know towards the center of the earth
well is that is there nothing here
nothing here
nothing came in contact with a pen
hopefully something came in contact with
the pen
and then something specifically either
pushed it down or pulled it down
something came in contact with the pen
otherwise you're introducing spirits
you're saying that this fell down by
magic that nothing came in contact but
it felt
simply because you can't see or touch
the mediator
okay so that's the issue so no you can't
see or touch the thread the rope we're
talking about something very thin very
small
you know in in one
centimeter cubic centimeter of air
you've got gazillions of atoms in there
it's unbelievable you can't even wrap
your hand head around how many particles
are in one cubic centimeter of
air let alone something a little more
dense
and all those are connected by ropes so
imagine if if the rope is to an atom
what uh
a thread a sewing thread right is to the
universe almost you know i mean you can
imagine how thin how small the thread
that we're talking about is the rope
okay so there's no way you can see it
even if you could see a rope you can
only see atoms and you cannot even see
an atom you can see what's made of atom
you can see the chair
but you cannot see one atom of the chair
and imagine the rope which connect which
is
to to the table
uh the atom is to the table what the
thread is to the atom
that or the rope to the atom we're
talking about something very thin very
small
so there's no way you're going to see
the rope or the thread
and the issue is whether
it has the ability of touch
touch is something that happens at the
atomic and greater level not at the
sub-atomic level you cannot touch the
rope because anything at the sub-atomic
level is untouchable unsealable you
can't see or touch it it's intangible
invisible and until you get that through
your head you're going to be rolling you
know chasing your tail around forever
okay so i don't know what these people
are looking for
uh okay uh follow says something about
the rotating fluid here says rotating
referring to he's referring to this let
me put this as a reference here okay
here we have uh my son who turned water
around
and the question is whether
water
the the atoms that make up water in
other words h2o whether they turned
around the atom itself the molecule
right whether the molecule stood on its
head over the molecule remained
bound by gravity to the center of the
earth did it maintain its position more
or less you know maybe it shook a little
bit but did it maintain that position
with respect to the center of the earth
or did it turn on its side did it stand
on his head
okay that's the question and so the
fella says
put this out of here it says rotating
container
about the horizontal axis must cause the
liquid to resettle to keep the surface
level under gravity but i can't say if
the molecules have tilted
and yeah again
i can't tell you either i'm just
throwing the question out there i
suspect that
in the case of water
it does maintain its uh direction with
respect to gravity in other words to the
center of the earth
under the rope model we have
ropes
tug uh on each one of those atoms that
form the water molecule the h2o so you
have ropes they have eight ropes
connected to the oxygen one rope
connected to each of the hydrogen you
have total ten ropes and the question is
does that molecule turn around and now
you have
the one rope from one of the hydrogen
pointed to the center of the earth and
the other eight
uh
right behind it you know going right
through it because ropes go right
through the atom
and or does it
does it stay in its uh
original direction does it level
off is it does it maintain its position
its location its tilt okay
and so by conventional physics i would
not expect a rotating
that rotating a balloon filled with a
gas to tilt the gas molecules because
they aren't connected to the balloon
container yeah if these molecules
you know they say they're moving around
but the question are they moving around
in any direction or are they all moving
around maintaining the same direction
with respect to the center of the earth
does the ox the o2 molecule which is two
oxygen molecules does it stand on its
head
or does it maintain this symmetric
situation with respect to the center of
the earth that's the question so when
you turn your balloon around what
happened to them air molecules inside it
did they turn around as well or did they
maintain their position that's the
question the gas molecules continue
under brownian motion until they are
redirected by collision with their
container
if the molecules impact a rotating
container maybe some of the rotation is
imparted on the molecules but otherwise
i didn't didn't see how the molecules
could be tilted
yeah neither can i um and all i can
do is again speculate because i don't i
can't tell you for for a fact i don't
have uh
god's eyes okay so i don't know if when
you tilt something like water in that
case there or um
or air
whether the molecule also turns i would
suspect not i would think that in
general
they move around they vibrate
but overall they maintain their
direction with respect to the center of
the earth in other words gravity
that's my guess okay
okay here's uh
another issue related to reflection
can of foul says you have to be [ __ ] a
[ __ ] to think your reflection is not
on the surface of water
okay uh
we have a little situation here okay and
this is an experiment you ran with ons
uh some time back okay and what we did
we put a mirror at the bottom of a trash
can okay
you can see it there now we're gonna
pour water in there okay and you know
when you pour water okay here here we're
filming the bottom of the we just put
the mirror round mirror at the bottom
there now we're gonna pour water in
there okay
and uh when we finish we can still see
ourselves at the bottom of the pool
okay
we can see we can see our image down at
the bottom
and so the question is
that reflection is from the surface
right there okay
we can see ourselves at the bottom of
that mirror at the bottom of the
which is at the bottom of the trash can
and so is the reflection coming from the
surface how come i can see the mirror
how come i can see myself in that mirror
if the mirror is at the bottom
okay file says that i'm getting that
reflection from the top
but the mirror is at the bottom
okay so uh
keep that in mind
it's easy to
reach a quick conclusion and the
question is whether that is true or not
okay
okay and then the final
thousands here
says
i was watching how vacuum decay would
destroy the universe pbs space time and
oh dow that matt o'dowd he does uh
pbs space time for pbs okay uh just
casually drop uh drops this line this
happens because quantum fields are
connected and tug at their adjacent
points across space
so here you have all these fields you
know that vibrating blue stuff that i
showed you earlier
and they're all connected
okay they're all uh
somehow they're connected across space
and he says and then he just uh just
goes on about something else after
dropping this bombshell everything is
connected and they don't think to figure
out how just a field did it
yeah and so that's the problem with
quantum mechanics they have no rational
explanations they use words like field
which is just a bunch of numbers but
then they talk about the interconnection
of fields meaning the interconnection of
a bunch of vibrating numbers what the
hell are you talking about what do you
mean a bunch of numbers are
interconnected what is a field
and so the word field represents numbers
and a lot of people have turned that
into physical object they think it's
some kind of strings that are vibrating
there or or you know like i say a
three-dimensional spider's web
that's not what a field is a field is
numbers
numbers don't vibrate
but they have vibrating fields and so on
so you figure out
okay so uh next time i'm going to
continue with the second installment and
we're going to look at another property
that produces
uh opacity and transparency okay